these are our culture teams top picks
for your reading list this book explores
why many men are falling behind and what
can be done about it this is the
astonishing story of a man who escaped
from Auschwitz to warn the world Agatha
Christie mysteriously disappeared for 11
days in 1926. so what happened set in
Trinidad this novel is a rich
examination of Love grief and
inheritance semiconductors power
everything from weapons to toasters this
book explains the geopolitics of chips a
Canadian journalist accompanies his
Afghan friend on a perilous journey to
Europe read this to find out how Britain
welcomed dirty money from Russian
oligarchs tycoons and tax Dodgers this
novel is a tale of racism and the legacy
of Injustice but it also manages to be
bitingly funny and finally the biography
of a pioneering plastic surgeon who
helped disfigured British soldiers
during the first World War